next on history on book TV a survey of
innovation in American history
you'll hear from co-authors of the new
book inventing America historians
Pauline Mayer Merritt Smith Daniel
Kellis and Alexander case are it's an
hour and a half I'd like to welcome
everyone to this evenings book
discussion at the Chicago Historical
Society my name is Steve Forman I'm the
editor of the book you'll be hearing
about inventing America a history of the
United States newly published by WW
Norton this is a history whose main
theme is innovation across all areas of
American life it locates an impulse in
Americans to break new ground to make it
new and follows this impulse to innovate
as it finds expression in politics
society the economy culture and in the
areas of Technology and science
those last two areas science and
technology are given the due attention
in this book that has been lacking in
histories of the United States for some
time the authors of this major new work
are all award-winning writers and
researchers I'll introduce all four to
you now in the order in which they'll
appear starting with Merritt Roe Smith
Roe is the originator of the project he
is the levirate and William cotton
professor of the history of Technology
at MIT rose research focuses on the
history of technological innovation and
social change and he is the author of
the groundbreaking work Harpers Ferry
armory and the new technology
Alex Kaiser is Matthew W sterling jr.
professor of history and Social Policy
at the John F Kennedy School of
Government Harvard University his
specialty is the political and social
history of modern America and his most
recent book is
the right to vote the contested history
of democracy in the United States
Pauline Mayer is William R Kenan jr.
professor of American history at MIT her
specialty is the period of the American
Revolution on which she has published
extensively Pauline's most recent book
is American Scripture making the
Declaration of Independence finally Dan
cave this is Stanley Woodward professor
of history at Yale University dan has
published extensively on the history of
science and the intersections of
politics science and technology in the
20th century most recently he's the
author of the Baltimore case a trial of
politics science and character after
hearing from each of the author's we'll
have some time for questions and
discussions and then we'll finish up
with a book signing in the in the
bookstore I'd like to thank you all
again for coming and now the authors of
inventing America
good evening my name is Merritt Rose
Smith one of the co-authors of inventing
America the question I want to pose at
the outset is why publish yet another
American history survey texts the
rationale I think is fairly
straightforward we call ourselves a
technological society yeah one would
hardly know that from our general
histories and classroom textbooks take
for example the first half of the
American history survey virtually all
texts and general histories of the
United States tend to include a chapter
or two on economic growth and lump into
that chapter everything that doesn't
seem to fit into the social or political
frame of analysis the result is the
technology science and economic
development are set apart from the
general narrative of politics and
society as if they have nothing to do
with the mainstream of American history
things are mentioned but little is
related we want to change that reading
and understanding of American history by
making some new connections equally
important is the present test
that students today are interested in
technology they use technology a lot
they believe implicitly
the science and technology have a big
part to play in their lives and yet they
have an utterly a historical sense of
what that all means our text and
contrast with others has the advantage
of meeting them where they are yet
educating them about their suppositions
one of our primary objectives is to help
readers understand the material world in
which they live and that undergirds our
society to put it another way we want to
integrate developments
Science and Technology into the
mainstream of American history integrate
with politics and society we believe
moreover that bringing technology and
science into the picture significantly
changes or reconfigures our
understanding of the American past the
late cyril Stanley Smith of MIT used to
say that one's angle of vision made all
made all the difference
clearly inserting elements of Science
and Technology into the narrative
changes the angle of vision on an
American history sometimes to clarify
and enliven subjects previously thought
not relevant or interesting for example
tariffs and at other times to cast
totally new light on historical
processes and events adopting the stance
allows us to say some pretty interesting
things about the intersections and
interactions that occur at certain nodal
points in American history
we believe that inventing America is an
apt title because a recurrent theme in
American history as we see it is
invention and innovation not only in
technology and science but also politics
society and the economy Americans have
been an innovative people we are also
interested in the larger social and
political implications both positive and
negative that science and technology
have had in the American experience
above all we've set out to view
America's history as a web sort of a
seamless web sometimes frayed at parts
that connects rather than isolates
politics science technology economy and
society the idea of an inter woven and
connected narrative is central to our
interpretation our editor Steve Forman
who you just heard from likes to say
that we are adding a new room to the
house of American history I like that
characterization the only thing I might
add is that I might like to substitute
fire
for room as a way of describing our
contribution is a new entry point or
hallway that connects with other major
rooms in the house what we would like to
do at this point is to point to some of
these entry points and connections by
way of example now we're under some
fairly tight time constraints so I think
each of us will choose one example and
then try to point to its larger
ramifications for the text as mentioned
before the theme is innovation Americans
as innovative people and the question
I'd like to address is the emergence of
time consciousness in the United States
how many of you are wearing a wristwatch
or carrying some sort of timekeeping
device this evening my guess is that
most of you are this example is about
why we came to be such a time oriented
people now the industrial city of Lowell
the city that literally exploded from an
obscure country village in 1821 to into
America's largest textile manufacturing
center in less than 20 years epitomizes
what Thomas Carlyle referred to as the
mechanical age at the center of this new
age was self-acting machinery machinery
that could be run by workers with a
modicum of training and could produce
thousands of yards of cloth in a single
day one thing we do in our textbook is
to try to convey the sense of sight
sound scale and precision that came with
mechanization we do this not only
through illustrations in the written
word but also through a video that
accompanies the textbook now as much as
lols textile mills came to symbolize the
mechanical age the so called city of
spindles was not an isolated instance of
industrialization equally if not more
important developments were taking place
elsewhere in New England and in the
middle
Atlantic states and we're spreading
rapidly to other parts of the country
particularly important here were the
clock and Firearms industries both
introduced widespread introduce
widespread use of novel middle working
and manufacturing techniques and the one
that was probably the earliest though
they were pretty contemporaneous with
each other was the clock industry and
which during the eighteen tens and
particularly right after the war of 1812
you began to see in and around Hartford
Connecticut a little west of Hartford
Connecticut Connecticut on a town called
Bristol the emergence of little shops
that were beginning to mass-produce
clocks with wooden parts at first and
then later by the late 1820s clocks that
had stamp brass parts that were made of
interchangeable parts these clocks were
shipped all over their country and sold
at very cheap prices as I recollect as
low as $2 a piece sometimes even less
than that the other area of interesting
innovation was also in New England along
the Connecticut River Valley and not far
from Hartford by the way in and around
Springfield Massachusetts where the
National armory there had begun to
coalesce around it all sorts of new
innovations that had been made by a
number of gun makers after the war of
1812 and became sort of a clearinghouse
for the introduction of interchangeable
manufacturing not just in the
manufacture of firearms but for for the
manufacture of all sorts of technically
related products that use similar
technologies for the manufacture for
example of sewing machines and then
later typewriters and then later
bicycles and ultimately automobiles so
these new manufacturing ventures
especially in clockmaking
and in arms making brought like the law
and text of interested an emphasis on
precision an emphasis on control an
emphasis on
system if you will America's armories
and clock factories and textile mills
joined by the postal system and emerging
transportation network and particularly
railroads after the 18th or during the
1830s had much in common most notably
they sought to impose and impose
uniformity and control on the shop floor
and along the line in order to achieve
speed scale and efficiency and of course
profits meeting these goals required
among other things the careful
management of work processes especially
the management of time factories had to
meet production schedules and
contractual obligations the post office
and railroads had to coordinate traffic
and meet delivery schedules such
requirements fostered a new sense of
time consciousness that had not existed
before equally important the new
emphasis on timekeeping and time
management had extremely important
consequences on a larger society now
what were these larger implications
perhaps the most challenging chapter I
wrote excuse me a second take a little
drink of water here the most challenging
chapter I wrote had to do with what I
called worker whirls in which I sought
to address free white farm labor slave
labor and factory workers and ask what
if anything that these three worlds of
work share in common
what really surprised me was the extent
to which all three communities were
becoming time conscious and especially
how the factory system influenced
timekeeping and time consciousness by
first producing cheap clocks and
marketed the marketing them throughout
the country indeed an English traveler
traveling in the Midwest during the
1840s rope in Kentucky Indiana Illinois
Missouri and even in every Dell of
Arkansas and in every cabin where there
was not a chair to sit on there was sure
to be a Connecticut clock
moreover factories became models that
plantation owners and other farming
groups like the shakers for example
sought to emulate by visiting places
like Lowell and Springfield and copying
their management styles
indeed southern slave plantations became
like many army camps in which clocks and
bugles called slaves to and from their
daily Labor's in the fields and finally
people of all walks of life became
increasingly tied to the time oriented
world of delivery schedules stage rivals
steamboats canals and most importantly
railroads to be sure there was
resistance to these new modes of thought
and action there were strikes workers
refusing to work according to clocks and
many instances sit-down strikes walking
off their job saying we refuse to be
made slaves of machines but these are
stories for another time it's quite
remarkable how quickly a nation remained
essentially agrarian in nature as late
as the 1860s adopted and adapted to the
time conscious ethos of the factory
counting-house and transportation
facility quite remarkable indeed thank
you
I'm going to begin with water which was
a major technological innovation in the
period that I worked on my name is Alex
Kesar and I want to begin actually by
making a couple of unplanned gratuitous
comments about about innovation and some
something about some fine lines that we
have been trying to deal with in in
writing this book one is that we have
tried very hard and I hope successfully
to point to the significance of
technology and science in American
history without writing a book which was
in anyway determinist which was in
anyway claiming that science technology
determined everything affected
everything that's certainly not anything
that we believe the second is that the
word innovation is a word which in
common usage tends to carry always a
positive connotation and yet I think
we've tried to stay very aware the fact
that not all innovations work and not
all innovations even if they do work are
necessarily good things for example as
we all know in recent months music years
we've been reading about the development
of some extremely innovating accounting
methods that have surfaced in the
American economy in the American
business know those are genuine
innovations but not necessarily ones
that that are positive for the nation as
a whole what I want to devote most of my
8 minutes of my time consciousness to
here those is is talking about some of
the ways in which the history of
Technology and science adds a
significant layer and recasts the
appearance of historical events and
historical developments and what I
particularly want to talk about is the
way in which
of Technology and science as lived as
experienced are integrated they're not
technology in science and technology in
particular not something that's out
there it's not something separate from
politics and society in the economy it's
something and we know this in our in our
own lives I mean we do but we tend not
to think of it when we when we think of
history and we think of change which has
a lot to do with the ways in which we
all traditionally were taught history
very much as as political history
isolated from what went on elsewhere and
I'd like to give two examples of this
kind of integration the first is the
Panama Canal there is a traditional
political history of the Panama Canal
which appears virtually in every
textbook in which most of us know it is
a story of the ambitions of the United
States to build a canal somewhere in
Central America it's a rather sordid
political story in which as again as
many of you do know Theodore Roosevelt
encouraged some people to rebel people
living in the province of Colombia that
was called Panama to rebel against the
central government of Colombia because
the government of Colombia had refused
to give us a canal treaty on terms that
we liked this political history then
proceeded there was a rebellion American
warships appeared in support of the
rebels and a Frenchman named Philippe vu
NVIDIA went to Washington declared
himself to be the Foreign Minister of
Panama where he had never lived and
negotiated a treaty with the United
States for the Panama Canal it's a
rather extraordinary political story and
and the story is generally told really
at this level of sort of political and
diplomatic history one can add in and
then historians in recent years have
tried to do this a social dimension to
this history because we know for that
building Panama Canal was
enormous engineering challenge and the
social historians began asking began
trying to find out well who built the
Panama Canal who actually did the work
and one of the discoveries and it
changes something of the complexion of
this story one of the discoveries is
that in fact there were two different
labor forces in Panama to build this
canal which took more than a decade one
which was called which was on what was
referred to as the gold payroll was
almost entirely white lords the American
consisted of skilled workers who were
came to Panama and lived and actually
rather comfortable circumstances where
were quite well-paid almost all the
physical labor however was done by
people who were on the quotes silver
payroll which meant that among other
things they were paid actually in
Panamanian currency or in other
currencies not in dollars these people
were almost entirely black although a
thousand were our Asians they were
largely blacks from the Caribbean
they lived in entirely segregated
quarters they lived in a complete
completely segregated ways they their
employment was not regulated by the
eight-hour laws which in theory at least
applied to government employees in the
United States and their fatality rates
were actually quite high so we have this
other dimension we have a diplomatic
story going on in Washington and to some
extent in Colombia and then Panama and
then we have the story of who these
people are actually digging it now
there's a and there's a third dimension
which we have tried to add in this book
which has to do with the history of
science and medicine and here we go back
to the fact that the the reason a
complicated story but the reason a
Frenchman came to declare himself the
foreign minister of Panama had to do
with the fact that the French had tried
to build a canal across the Isthmus of
Panama and they had failed and they had
failed really for one reason and it's a
reason there was not because they lacked
the engineering acumen of Americans they
failed because of diseases and because
of diseases particularly yellow fever
that's
struck the powder at the Panamanian
peninsula were so deadly that they could
not recruit a labor force the key in
fact to Americans success in building 20
25 years later an American success in
building the canal was the discover the
development of better understandings of
disease in the understanding of the
bacteriological origins of diseases
particularly yellow fever ironically a
lot of this research was conducted in
France but it was it was a it was
applied by the United States when the
United States began digging digging the
canal it had first had the same problems
the French had anybody who went there to
work died which made it an unpopular
destination for workers with our highly
skilled or unskilled the u.s. actually
stopped for all construction for a while
and sent in a team this is really in
some sense the first public health
experts anywhere in the world went in
and cleaned up the area in some way sort
of spraying areas getting rid of
mosquitoes eliminating the sources of of
disease and then resumed construction
they were then able to recruit a labor
force and then able to build and then
the major engineering challenge which
faced the United States I mean you know
in in effect the United Sates was able
to do that because of medical advances
that had nothing to do with the United
States the engineering successes of the
United States were very mundane but also
equally significant what the United
States where engineer American engineers
figured out how to do was to move an
extraordinary amount of dirt digging the
Panama Canal produced 330 million tons
of dirt that had to be moved and the
Americans got involved in a process of
building a railroad to move the dirt
away from the taking sites the Panama
Railroad in 1910 was the busiest
railroad in the world its passengers
were largely small particles of dust and
then there were other engineering
challenges as well such as where to put
the dirt how to dump it quickly but what
I'm trying to get out here is that when
we look at the Panama Canal when we
this extraordinary achievement which
symbolized and further American imperial
ambitions at the at the turn of the
century this is a story which to tell
correctly to tell right involves both
politics diplomacy social history and
the material history that comes from
looking at technology and science my
second example and then and then I will
desist because a different type of
example which is the history the role of
electricity in American history now here
is in this case unlike the Panama Canal
were not starting with the political
event we're starting with something
which was technological and in most
histories of of the United States there
is some respect paid to this almost
every US history survey has a long
paragraph about Thomas Edison and we all
know Thomas Edison and the lightbulb and
and that's true this is a significant
technological advance building on some
things that have been known for a long
time taking it one step further with the
kind of focus that we've tried to give
the science of technology what we see is
that not just Edison developing the
incandescent light bulb but we see
Edison developing a new technological
system of electricity and part of
Edison's genius was that he understood
this he understood that inventions
didn't happen in isolation from one
another that death electricity depended
on building sort of dynamos to produce
the electricity you had to have ways of
transmitting it you had to have ways of
controlling it and then you had to have
those matched to various appliances or
utilities that would run on electricity
he understood the value of this so here
we have that happen at the technological
and economic end of it and then of
course there is an extraordinarily
important social history of Technology
if one continues to sort of to look at
the socialist row of electricity excuse
me
and here one can point to workplaces
where electricity just changes all the
sounds in the workplace it changes the
location of machinery in the workplace
it makes workplaces much less dangerous
electric power is far less likely to
produce fires than other forms of power
it produces a steady light newspaper
compositors were among the first to use
electric lights they were so overjoyed
at having a predictable and reliable and
secure basis of light for the fine work
that they did
night after night similarly in the
American homes one can look at a social
history of electricity at the way in
which it changes light patterns it
permits people to do things at different
times and it encourages the creation of
and invention and innovation of all
sorts of appliances which changed the
way the domestic work is performed but
there is also and again I I use this
again as an example of the ways in which
these things are integrated there is
also a significant political history of
electricity and the political history of
electricity is a history of a debate
that takes place between 1890 and the
1920s about whether electricity should
be a public good controlled by
municipalities or States and distributed
to everyone as a common good or whether
it should be a private commodity
controlled by private corporations and
run according to market principles in
1890 and in 1900 there were some areas
which worked on the public good model
others on the private commodity model
there were very widespread debates which
I think will be very resonant to anyone
familiar with the history of the
internet for example and in the end by
the early 1920s it was clear that the
private commodity forces had won in part
because of the extremely effective
lobbying efforts of very large
corporations which themselves the
benefit from their control of
electricity and electric power and
appliances run on electricity and that
was the way it remained one consequence
of which
was that almost all of rural America
which was so thinly populated that it
was much less likely to generate profits
for companies remained on electrified
until the 1930s when the federal
government stepped in and filled this
void creating something of a model of
development of economic development in
the United States of letting private
forces and markets do their work and
having the government step in afterwards
to fill the holes again I mentioned this
as an example of the integration of the
stories of you know of politics
of social life edit of Technology and
science which are very and as that
integration is something that we live
with and it's a part of us today but
which we in this book have been trying
to restore to the understanding of
history thank you
I'm Pauline mayor you may have noticed
the two of us are on the MIT faculty and
that may be the reason why Roe Smith
several years ago asked me to join the
team that was going to write this
textbook at the time I had no real
interest in writing a textbook I done
that once I wrote a wall-to-wall
beginning to end
textbook for junior high school in the
early 1980s and I figured if you do that
once that's enough for a career there
are other things to do in life but a
textbook that would for the first time
give serious attention to the history of
Science and Technology had an unexpected
appeal I'm not a historian of science or
technology I'm what I will call a plain
vanila early American historian but I
figured I could learn what I didn't know
and there's always something very
exciting about learning something new
and I also thought that perhaps bringing
these new elements into the story the
story itself would change in some
interesting ways and would be
fascinating to see how that happened the
analogy I had in mind I'll confess was
something rather simple family dinners
you may notice how much conversations
change and really the whole character of
an event changes depending on who is
present in a given night and I suppose
who is absent and I wondered if you know
the story of American history would
undergo a similar kind of a
transformation if you brought in topics
which had been under played in the past
or ignored
now several years later might well ask
whether that expectation was true and
you will not be surprised if I say I
think actually that is what's happened
the story we tell in this book is not
unfamiliar you know Virginia and
Massachusetts are still founded in the
same year independence still comes in
1776 Washington still the first
presidents civil war depression all come
in on cue but I think bringing in these
new elements allow us to tell that
Miller story indeed by bringing in
elements that should have been there all
along we can tell that familiar story
with with a certain freshness my task
here I guess is to illustrate this with
reference to the period that I covered
and the period I covered here was not
wall to wall it's just the first date
chapters which I'd like to say began at
a vague point and entered that one
that's very precise I start with what I
call the misty origins of human
occupation of the Americas when was it
that the first humans migrated to the
Americas was it 40,000 years ago or
thirty thousand years ago maybe ten
thousand years ago I mean this is
indeterminacy with a vengeance but it
ends my portion ends the moment Thomas
Jefferson put down his inaugural address
and actually Roe Smith and I had a
little dispute over where the transition
would be between my chapter and his and
I told him that Jefferson's inaugural
address on March 4th 1801 was the end of
the 18th century so I got it and that's
where I end but it's very clear if you
think about this vast period of time
that I was supposed to cover or
Chronicle and some in some measure that
it's not what any of us would think of
as a heyday of a technological society
there were no antibiotics there were no
computers there were no electronic
telecommunications etc etc etc but
technology if you think about it is
really just the mechanical or our
contrived means that people come upon to
perform some task which is useful to
them and if you use this very Catholic
definition of technology it allows one
to ask a whole series of question which
I think human curiosity often asks how
did they do it you know how did the
Norseman or subsequent europeans or the
renaissance make it across the ocean
I mean they thought there was one ocean
the great ocean sea to get to a place
roughly where they wanted to go although
they had no landmarks to guide them how
subsequently did navigation become more
predictable and what would what what
what aids did were developed for that
purpose we would like to know how what
kind of shelter people had and how they
built it what did people eat and how did
they prepare it how did they eat it for
that matter it turns out we have a
wonderful story and a little feature
that runs a little book called what's
for dinner of a story of a family in the
18th century that eats a whole fish with
its hands you know the observer was
appalled to see they were eating the
scales the skin everything with their
hands it nuns probably we're not
uncommon mode of eating in the 17th
century people ate a lot of stews
particularly with spoons then you move
on to the 18th century where you know
you get the arrival of standard cutlery
that we're so used to but it happens at
a point in time all of these obviously
this allows us to talk a great deal
about ordinary everyday life which is
extremely fashionable among historians
today what was surprising to me and not
entirely as that anticipated was how
much an interest in technology would
allow us to integrate that history of
everyday life with a rather more
traditional history of government and
politics with that in mind I want to
talk about my chapter six which is in a
section on the American Revolution the
previous chapter talks about the
development of independence in the
Revolutionary War in Chapter six I talk
about the transformations the changes
that occurred within the States which
were of course far more important than
the nation at that point in time and
indeed would be the primary locus of
power in the United States until I would
say the 1930s it begins the chapter
begins with a very careful attention to
the writing of the
state constitutions which began in 1776
and the last of the first I should say
was written in 1780 in Massachusetts to
us I think you know the the design of
political institutions isn't necessarily
the most exciting subject in the world
but we have to get our minds back our
heads back into the in mentality of that
time where this was really these subject
that attracted the best minds of the age
I think often of a letter John Adams
wrote to the Virginia and George whiff
in which he said that he that is Adams
and with lived in a time when the
greatest law givers of the ancient world
would have wish to live when he asked
had men before had an opportunity to
design the government's under which they
and their children would live it was the
first time is extraordinarily exciting
and the first crack the head at that
subject was within the states and
designing state constitutions the first
ones had a whole series of other bizarre
institutions councils of this councils
of that councils of sensors even or
something very weird called an electoral
college but after well these changes in
the form of institutions fell into
certain patterns and from that that
trace train of development we can see
very easily the Federal Constitution
emerging so there's a certain continuity
between the state and the national level
but in fact I would go one step further
I would say the revolution is the period
where Americans first embraced
innovation as something which was good
change was a was not unfamiliar to them
they lived through a tremendous amount
of change but the change that they knew
in the colonial period they saw as
allowing them to approximate more and
more the British model moving away from
the very idea Socratic primitive ways of
say their first settlements in the 17th
century toward so that they would look
more and more like their model of
culture and civilization and achievement
which was Great Britain
with the Revolution where they cut loose
from that model I'm not saying that they
forgot it entirely but they were gonna
go one step further they were going to
do it better they were going to innovate
they were gonna make it better and they
did this they started creating
institutions that were dramatically
different and none neither the state nor
the federal constitutions were very much
like Britain's unwritten Constitution
some similarities yet but the whole
distribution of power was different and
the fact that they're written one way
after another these are very different
than anything that existed in Britain
and I think this sort of movement toward
innovation got going and they made other
changes many of these are on the social
level state legislatures for example
passed gradual emancipation laws this is
the beginning of the dismantlement of
the institution of slavery in the United
States but there are other changes which
are less familiar that were also great
interest to me they fall more I suppose
in the area of technological or economic
change state legislatures for example
passed some of the first patent laws in
the history of the United States and
they did that even though in the
colonial period they had none on their
law books these were often private acts
that is special acts of legislators to
give an individual a patent on a device
I became fascinated with the kind of
inventions that were being patented to
tell a complicated story simply I think
wherever there was some obstacle to
economic development
somebody somewhere came up with a gizmo
that would fix it and help get people
past that obstacle let me give you a
couple examples one fellow invented
something called a trigonometric i've
does a device for solving trigonometric
and land' you think in the United States
at this period of times in the 1780s
there's a lot of land left to be
surveyed as I suspect anybody realizes
has taken a coast-to-coast airplane and
ride and looked out the window and
noticed I we've divided a continent into
square
and rectangles wherever the topography
allows so regular a line of division
there were other devices I mean already
Steam Navigation is getting a lot of
people interested and the reason in the
1780s I think is pretty clear places in
the West like Kentucky were emerging as
major markets for goods that were
imported or manufactured along the
Atlantic coast but getting there was a
bit of a trial because for a good bit of
the route the rivers went the wrong way
so you were going upstream Steve
navigation would solve that and so
they're working at although there is no
real solution no viable solution until
the 19th century
they're trying out they're really trying
by God they're trying another big
problem labor costs and here we get the
wonderful innovation of a man named
Oliver Evans whose name rarely appears
in textbooks he managed to get patents
in several states for an fully automated
flour mill where which would require no
human labor whatsoever and he actually
built these mills which historians of
technology described as the first
example of fully automated production
anywhere in the world so a rather
remarkable achievement one other
obstacle required a different approach
if labor costs were a major obstacle to
the development of manufacturing a
dearth of ready capital was another
there are no venture capitalists in the
United States at this period no very
wealthy man wealth was relatively
equally distributed through the
population with some regional variations
of course what the legislators do to
approach this although I'm not going to
say it's their primary incentive is to
development to begin the development of
an institution which is quite familiar
to us the corporation the corporation is
an old legal institution but it was
tainted with the ciseaux by an
association with monopolies and
privilege what the state legislatures do
full of enthusiasm for their capacity to
fix what was wrong and models from the
past rip into the Constitution
and redesign charters so that they are
less subject to criticism for their
monopolistic or privileged character and
then they start passing acts of
incorporation I mean they're
incorporating a lot of non economic in
institutions towns cities schools etc
but they also in course start to
incorporate some very interesting
business enterprises and there they have
a terrific advantage they could still
sell stock to a large number of people
and collect their capital from small
contributions from a large number of
people these this stock of capital was
used to build bridges to improve rivers
to make roads
much of the early transportation
infrastructure of this country was built
through corporations and they also were
used to found the country's first banks
there were no real significant banks in
the colonial period of any of any
importance the first come out of the
1780s and they are incorporated think of
what that means to the financial
structure of the country think of what
it means for its future development now
I want to suggest these are really new
topics and textbooks you'll find
textbooks that we'll talk about the
first day constitutions occasionally
often they're skipped over so the
Federal Constitution sort of seems to
come like the Ten Commandments a gift
from God given on tablets not out of a
period of experiment experimentation
that preceded it it's these are all I
think important I don't think you'll
find a textbook that talks about patent
laws I don't think you'll find anything
talk about copyright which develops
simultaneously much less the beginning
of corporations for text book these are
new topics I should I think however like
Alex have one rejoinder here when you
talk about innovation I think we tend to
have a kind of a triumphal character to
this it doesn't always hold true a
desire to innovate is one thing a
capacity to pull it off is something
very distinct and quite different in the
United States couldn't pull off an awful
lot of it's great innovative schemes I
the chapter I wrote on the 1790 says a
section called the problem with dreams
the Passaic and the Potomac and it
isolates two very ambitious projects
that went bad one was an effort to found
a very complex industrial enterprise
roughly but isn't it Paterson New Jersey
basically and it essentially went bust
by 1796 and the other on the Potomac is
this grandiose scheme to found the
national capital of Washington DC I
think it was no less beyond the
capacities of Americans at that period
in time you may well be aware that it
took 71 years to finish building the
National Capitol the building the
Capitol what was lacking well management
skills we think of management skills as
sort of you know reflexes and they're of
Americans you know the country that they
you know the the the quintessential
business beginning of the business
schools are also a series of specialized
skills architecture among them that were
just not very much present in the United
States in the 1790s it took time for
management skills for these other skills
to be developed a rome wasn't built in a
day neither was the United States but
all of this allows us to do I think is
to go back and look at traditional
subjects with new eyes and I would hope
at least I've persuaded you that it's
possible to talk about the American
Revolution in a rather different way if
you bring in these aspects of the story
I knew when I began from what I had
written in my book American scripture
that the Americans adopted independence
they said because they had no choice if
left to their own preferences they would
have remained British Kover once they
did declare their independence and put
themselves in charge of their own lives
it seems they look to the future and
they never look back thank you
good evening I'm Dan Kellis from Yale
University when I was given the
opportunity late in the last century to
participate in the writing of inventing
America I jumped at the chance and main
reason major reason I did so back the
major reason was that long thought that
the treatment of the overall American
narrative really required the
integration of science and technology
into the story it's difficult to imagine
if you look at the 20th century which is
the period that I've written about I
wrote the chapter the chapters since the
1930s it's difficult to imagine how a
treatment of the United States in the
20th century especially the latter part
of the century could be complete without
the treatment of science and technology
some technologies for example nuclear
weapons intercontinental ballistic
missiles jet aircraft have transformed
the role of the United States in the
world others many of them spin-offs of
national security have dramatically
changed the economy and health and daily
life I need only mention antibiotics
television cell phones computers
microwave ovens birth control pills
plastic synthetic fabrics and the
Internet
the I must stress though that our book
and my intention in writing this and
participating in the writing in this
book is not a in the end a history of
science and technology this is not the
story of quantum mechanics or molecular
biology or what have you this is the
history of the United States as we
conventionally understand it
in which however it that in a way but
that is dealt with in a way an enriched
way because it integrates science and
technology into the story we have tried
to make this accomplish this integration
in a way that both teachers and students
will fought will find compatible with
their aims of learning and presenting
the main elements of the American
historical experience we introduce the
science and technology not for its own
sake but with the aim of showing where
and when it has exercise consequences
for the social economic and political
and national security narrative it is
thus made part of those subjects
innovation is obvious is an obvious
ingredient in the development of science
and technology and so it has been in the
twentieth century for sure but
innovation in our institutions and our
social values in our economic
Arrangements have continued throughout
our history to to has continued
throughout our history to be a major
force in the shaping of our nation and
our society and what we have sought to
do is to couple and integrate the
innovations of both types for example my
co-authors have already mentioned to you
that throughout the book we have a
muddler motif of the American Journal
that tells you in a vignette like
fashion what how science and technology
have affected essential elements of
daily life what's for dinner for example
or to mention something that hasn't yet
been mentioned what happens when you get
sick we take for granted what happens
when you get sick now but it wasn't
always that way and this is if anything
certainly an essential part of
people live for example in the late
1940s if you came down with an
infectious disease such as measles or
scarlet fever or what have you you were
quarantined you were not quarantined in
the hospital you were quarantined in
your own room and your mother who was
usually the caregiver in the family
would have to come in and dr. Spock
recommended in the first edition of his
book that you that the mother should
come in and she should Don a clean white
smock and should take care of you
minister to you and then remove the
smock and leave the room so that she
would not bring any more germs any germs
outside of the room antibiotics and
vaccinations changed all that and you
all know that when you get sick with an
infectious disease you don't have to be
quarantined anymore the features of
Science and Technology by putting the
features of science and technology into
the story we also think that we can
reach out our teachers can reach out in
instructing about the American narrative
more effectively to the students who
appear in their classes the kids coming
into today's history classrooms are
unprecedented ly familiar and
comfortable with high technology they
are if you will astonishing parallel
processors able to watch television surf
the web listen to music and do their
homework all at the same time putting
science and technology into the American
story gives them something to hook on to
in the past it helps make history
relevant because it explains how part of
the world of their own experience came
into being
another reason for integrating science
and technology into the story is that is
precisely because that experience of
Science and Technology certainly in our
own day is of course by no means all
positive either for for us or for
as individuals or for our society one
need think only of the technologies of
say terrorism or surveillance or of
pollution but we show that science and
technology does not condemn us to
hapless victim point we do this by
showing that innovation has been been
always a product of human effort whether
was Edison sweating to produce electric
light and power systems or physicists
struggling to devise microwave radar in
World War two or biomedical scientists
trying to deal with polio learning that
science and technology has been a
product of human agency students and all
other readers can recognize that it is
within the bounds of human democratic
control let me just close by providing
an illustration of recent history how
the integration of innovation in science
and technology with innovations in
values and social arrangements can work
has worked enormously transforming
effects and what I want to discuss is
the women's movement in the last 30 or
40 years one can make the argument and
it has been made that in a number of
ways the women's rights movement has
marked the revolution and social
arrangements about as significant as the
revolution of 1776 and its implications
and consequences are still being worked
out the innovations that of the
innovations that assisted the movement
occurred partly in the social and legal
area for example we have title 9 of the
education amendments Act of 1972 that
banned discrimination in against women
in the use of federal federally financed
athletic facilities the result was that
was to produce a dramatic impact in
women's sports for example a three-fold
increase to 25 percent and the
participation of
girls in high school athletics doubts as
to the capabilities of women were
significantly dispelled when in 1973 the
tennis champion Billie Jean King an
outspoken enemy of sexism in sports and
a founder of the Virginia Slims tennis
tour trout's the 1939 Wimbledon champion
Bobby Riggs who had taught at her to
prove that she could beat quote a tired
old man it's clearly also another
innovation that contributed to the
women's movement and the creation of
greater equality and Liberty for women
was the birth control pill this is a an
element in the desire of women or the
drive of women to achieve a much greater
control over their own bodies and their
of course their sexual lives but this
this the pill did not just come about
because some scientists on place decided
there should be a pill it came about
because feminists such as Margaret
Sanger a longtime champion of birth
control going back all the way through
the period just before World War 1 a
joined with other women some of whom had
a good deal of money to foster research
in contraception and in the basic
physiology of conception which you had
to know about in order to prevent
prevent it it was this effort that
provided the funds and the encouragement
for scientists who then came up with the
pill that came on the market in the
early 1960s the pill I mean the control
over for women of control of women for
their own bodies led ultimately in the
the decision of roe v wade under the
united made by the united states supreme
court in 1973 to guarantee a woman's a
woman's right to have an abortion up to
a certain point in the din of pregnancy
here is perhaps one of the greatest
innovations a long time - a long
tradition in the history of the American
Supreme Court because here the court
found in the bill of rights something
that is not explicitly there namely it
found in the pen um what is called the
penumbra of the right of privacy the
right of a woman to control her own
reproductive life this was a hallmark of
the kind of constitutional and legal
innovation that joined together with
with the laws passed by the Congress by
the states and also by the technology of
the birth control pill to provide women
with increasing control over their own
lives and their own bodies this is not
to say that all innovation and
particularly in the women's movement the
kind of innovations I've just described
were happily welcomed by all Americans
they were not you are all familiar sure
with the backlash against the women's
liberation movement of the 1970s and of
the 60s and the early 70s and in
particular the backlash against the
women of the right of a woman to choose
but in understanding the development of
the United States we have to understand
that the DRI for innovation has often
produced backlashes and how we cope with
those things with those kind of
backlashes as well of the innovations
are rooted in our understanding of their
historical roots the innovations of in
the women's movement in the 60s and 70s
together with the backlash after all
have shaped the agenda of the latter
part of the 20th century helped shape
the the political and social agenda of
the last part of the 20th century and
continue to shape that on the early part
of this century thank you
I'd like to thank row Alex Pauline and
Dan for those fascinating glimpses into
a history of the United States that is
fresh and that as just Roe was
suggesting is really the first book in a
generation to enlarge the house of
American history by building a new
dimension into the story we do have some
time for questions and I'd like to
invite the authors to come up and sit
with us up on the stage and we'll take
some some questions from the audience
you have a question please if you can
make your way to the mic and speak into
the mic over there
all right thank you what's your name my
name is Casey I'll try and stay on
subject here sometimes I have a tendency
to wander but um I guess I'd like to
start off by asking you how you felt yes
Pauline you brought this up in your talk
somewhat and some of the earlier talks
and just this last point that was
brought up about some of the backlash
against the rise in technology and
Pauline I was thinking about how you
brought up the rise of banks in the US
and how that led to a change in the
economy and how that affected the rural
portions of the United States during and
around the period of the American
Revolution how do you think how do you
see technology as a radicalizing force
in the United States and both maybe
adding too conservative radical
movements and then also on the other end
progressive radical movements such as
maybe the kind of utopian movements of
the late 19th century if you just
expound on that a little bit Thanks well
I'll start since you mentioned me but I
suspect Rowe would have more to say on
some of these utopian movements
particularly early 19th century but
you're certainly correct that there was
a radical backlash to the first banks
they had quite traditional arguments to
be used that is that they are privileged
in some people over others but what
would I discovered is that there was not
so much a movement against banks as
there was a movement that questions the
way some of the first like the Bank of
North America had been structured and so
basically it became again a controversy
over how you create these institutions
not against the the character of those
institutions but that was the whole
story if you wanted to figure out who is
going to be benefited and who was going
to be heard
that's what that that was the issue that
had to be addressed and among other
changes that were demanded was that
these be so structured that they had
benefits for people in the rural areas
not just for those who are involved in
in commerce but the controversy was so
severe particularly over the bank of New
York that I think the delegates to the
Constitutional Convention thought that
adding a federal right to incorporate to
the Constitution would have just added
to the opposition and conceivably the
document ever have been ratified so they
didn't put it there which is the reason
why that still it really read her vein
primarily at the state level state and
corporation but role what about these
utopian movements well the thing that
comes to mind for me is really two
groups one one would be utopian groups
of the pre Civil War period who you know
we're very much an sort of an ambivalent
group about technology on the one hand
you'd have people associated with the
transcendentalist movement you know
bemoaning technology in one breath and
yet using it in others various
communities that are earlier actually
and not associate with the
transcendentalist like New Harmony in
Indiana relied heavily on you know
adapting and new technologies to say the
manufacturer of cloth there was another
group the shakers who in fact were not
only adapters of technology but
inventors the shakers proved to be very
adept at developing new technologies
that spread into the into the larger
culture I'm thinking for example the
circular saw which is a basic
woodworking tool that if anyone is a
woodworker you know immediately you know
what a circular saw is so those you know
those groups were basically especially
if they had a religious bent
they tended to be very interested in new
techniques and not only borrowed them
but also tried to develop them and I've
heard it said and I haven't I this is
something I haven't actually researched
but I've heard it said that one of the
reasons for that is is that they felt
religious groups at least felt that if
you were going to lighten your labor by
developing new technologies a circular
saw incentive us hand saw for example
that was going to give you more time for
the important thing in life which is
prayer and contemplation and surely the
shakers were very much in that and that
sort of groove there were others called
the perfectionist the oneida
perfectionist who were very much wrapped
up in industrial production producing
you know steel traps and then later the
sort of eating ware that we're all
familiar with so a knight a silver plate
so you get you know those sorts of
groups that are very much I think into
the technology of the age and adapt it
now there's one other group that is
neither it's surely not a religious
oriented group but they are reformers of
the period and that is people who came
out of evangelical backgrounds and
became you know well among the earliest
proponents of abolition is in the United
States those groups actually adapted
steam powered technologies of printing
to disseminate you know hundreds of
thousands of tracks not only in the
north but also in the South you know
espousing their causes whether it was
abolitionism or temperance or pacifism
the great tract movement of the pre
Civil War period was you know ode to the
fact that they these groups were early
comers and users of these new
technologies that were made available so
you know there were both utopian groups
religious groups and reform groups who
may or may not had a religious
orientation you know were very much sort
of involved in the new technology and at
the same time they also critiqued it I
also have a couple of comments in
response to your question first I think
it's important
and we all know this but it's important
to underscore that you and under the
rubric of Technology are a lot of
different kinds of things and and the
way in which those technologies are
located in the society different mean
there's there's very little opposition
to penicillin
for example you know or people are an
even very little opposition to the air
brake in late 19th century railroads
which reduced the carnage among brakeman
which was you know which was it which
was extraordinary but there are other
technological changes which are you know
farm were loaded and which are connected
to institutions of power involving
either the economy or the sword in some
circumstances the state and part of what
we've tried to do is to locate those
those kinds of changes by you know
talking about technology not just coming
out of the blue but you know somebody
does it somebody invents it things do
change and I think that they often do
have radicalizing elements I mean we
certainly know for example that
transformations in the work place that
were occasioned by technological and
organizational reforms of the late 19th
and early 20th century and indeed
they're actually Antebellum examples of
this as well
radicalized large numbers of workers and
then we also know that the revolt of the
farmers in the late 19th century their
symbolic enemy the major enemy was the
railroad when the railroad in the late
19th century is the most significant
means of technological development in a
series of answers but it is the most
significant economic and social and
perhaps political institution of the era
and the populace revolts are I mean
there there was a lot going on but the
the the enemy is are the railroads and
the railroad corporations and and it's a
radicalization of the farmers in
response to that to add a coda to what
Alex has just said and row as well if
you look as say at the student revolts
of the 1960s
they're denunciations of technology as
such but what was meant was the
technology of warfare
and in that and of national security in
the context of the Vietnam War and the
arms race and the anti-ballistic missile
systems but there was certainly no
rejection of the technologies such as
contraceptive pills antibiotics stereos
or taking the jet airplane home for
Christmas vacation and so you when you
have to be attentive to we have tried to
be attentive to the differentiations in
the technologies and the degree to or
the or their associations with
institutions of power or whether whether
they are perceived to enlarge freedom
and autonomy for the individual or not
saying I think that one of the
interesting things about the text that
we've written is that there are many
ironies when you discuss the
infiltration and adaption of new
technologies in society and one of the
ironies that reflects on what alex is
saying is that oftentimes a new machines
are developed self-acting machines
machines have speed up and increased
production when they're developed it's
often times the workers who are right in
the middle of the development of those
machines they are not resisting them
they're actually designing helping to
design the machines and I've seen
instances of this in the Middle working
industry but at the same time once those
machines are introduced and once they
begin to actually indicate that there
are you know that piece rates increase
as a result of this and people are
taking home our morning you begin to get
conflicts between those who own the
machines and those who are running them
over what the peace rates are going to
be that's when you have things like
strikes and yet you know to say that
workers are anti technology surely in
the pre Civil War period is a vast
oversimplification most workers are very
much involved in the whole process less
resistance to mechanical innovations
here then you get in some place I
you know I curious to be thinking of
examples from the 17th century but Mills
for example what the whole landscape is
sort of dotted with Mills of that in the
early colonial period particularly New
England gristmills
sawmills and many of these you know were
resisted in in England the creation of
not so much gristmills but other kinds
if they displace labour but here labour
wasn't such short supply that by and
large any may any device that allowed
work to be done with fewer workers was
what was welcomed it's a good question
thank you Casey I hope I hope we've over
answered it or have we have we failed to
answer Kyle I was just wondering what
role you saw technological innovation
playing and changing ideas of American
democracy and issues of popular
sovereignty and majoritarianism
particularly maybe in the late 18th or
the 19th century well I can say
something about the early 20th century
if that's okay
you know the there was a an expectation
in the late 19th and early 20th
centuries that the difficulties and
inequalities of urban industrialized
society might be solved by bringing to
these problems so a kind of scientific
approach the authority of science and
the powers of science were already
manifest as a result of the Second
Industrial Revolution that started in
the 1870s by which I mean the
development of electric light streetcars
the chemical industry and so on
but at the same time you had the rise of
enormous corporate power the Trust's
consumer problems with products faulty
products and so on problems of railroads
rates transportation etc traction
systems within cities and so people
began to say the reformist bent that if
we could only apply the or take the the
the methods of science and the
disinterestedness of the science of X
period and and bring it to bear on how
we could reconstruct and control our
society for progressive democratic
purposes then we would have it we would
achieve significant reform and a the
application of this of this vision if
you will can be found in the progressive
reforms many of them of the early 20th
century particularly with the
establishment of the regulatory agencies
of government and we know now and people
learned not not too long afterwards that
the expectation that just by being
scientific and so on gathering data
trying to be disinterested and so on
would not necessarily lead to beneficial
results because in the end what counted
was power not necessarily knowledge all
by itself but this doesn't should not
depreciate or diminish the significance
of the expectation that by embracing
scientific modes of analysis and of
governance that you could create a more
equitable society I think that to a
significant degree the idea that
knowledge disinterest in this and good
will all combined can
can through the innovation of
institutions be brought to can bring us
a a better society but we have to keep
rehab we have throughout our history
kept renewing and reforming the way we
have brought these scientific methods
and scientific spirit and democratic
expectations to bear on the problems of
power and inequity in our society but
the scientific expectation was there and
I think continues to remain there let me
also add add something to that and even
with a slightly different emphasis
because again I don't think we can find
easy generalizations about the
relationship between you know Science
and Technology and democratization or
you know or the or the lack thereof but
to give it a different kind of example
even dealing with the same period and a
little bit later is that and Dan was
alluding to this in part is that there
there is also in the early 20th century
focused on science technology and
expertise there is an anti-democratic
current and the same people who pass a
lot of these regulatory reforms also
interested in disfranchising immigrants
and getting rid of mayors running cities
and creating city managers who will be
experts so there's this anti you know
there is a kind of of anti-democratic
currents which in part you know one can
see in the primacy of the figure of the
engineer in the early 20th century and
one way and it's a little bit you know
it's a little bit too much of a parable
but sometimes history offers us
simple-minded parables and and part of
the way in which I think we try to tell
the story is that the person who became
the epitome of of this as a move of the
engineer as it moves into politics is of
course Herbert Hoover who was the great
engineer
of the period and as you no doubt know
was not is not remembered as one of our
great presidents and the collapse of
Hoover's presidency is inability to deal
not not only with the economic crisis of
the New Deal but with the political or
than of the Great Depression but the
political crisis the Great Depression to
some extent sort of you know kind of
sort of an undercut and I think for a
time put aside something of that model
now I don't think it disappears from
American history indeed I think one
could almost argue that Bill Clinton in
a way represented a kind of resurgence
of a sort of technocratic kind of model
but but I you know it does have a
history I'll push it back into the pre
Civil War period I think there's
something this is sort of a radical
statement but there's something
inherently anti-democratic about new
technologies of their in the sense that
especially I'm thinking of mechanical
technologies the type of technologies
that were deep being deployed in
factories and on railroads to the in the
sense that they were requiring increased
management increased control increased
order in the workplace and in that sense
it meant not liberating people but you
know sort of putting their wings around
them hold him in holding them in place
you know there's I think there's a lot
of truth to that statement
the really at least one of the
interesting things that I discovered in
writing this textbook was that the
really democratizing forces and in at
least early 19th century America were
religion the rise of evangelical
religious groups who you know groups
that believed that in the priesthood of
all believers and the idea that you know
people the people what was there's a
famous expression that you know people
were the
you know sort of the governing force of
churches the governance of churches were
inherently democratic when you talk
about Baptist organizations who ran the
church who chose the mentum of the
preachers the people did you know those
sorts of governance and governing
procedures had a lot of impact I think
on the nature of democracy in the spread
of democracy in the early you know the
early 19th century religion is extremely
important at that time far I think far
more important that it is today
and it and especially among these
evangelical groups it's tended to
emphasize you know the Democratic
aspects of society the interesting thing
is that I think those things get played
out in politics and the the example that
I was going to mention is the Charles
River Bridge case I think the date is
1837 in which the court under Roger
tawny and strikes down a charter that
had been granted to a group of Boston
investors in effect arguing that the
corporation was monopolizing the
movement of people across this bridge
and that it was really you know against
the interest of the people to connect to
have such a monopoly now if John
Marshall had been chief justice at that
time I doubt very much that he would
have struck down that law because he was
a great believer in the obligation of
contracts but over the course of time
you can see this getting played out you
know among the members of the emerging
Democratic Party at that time surely
Roger tawny was a Jacksonian you know a
believer and they quote power the people
or whatever the majesty of the people I
think was the expression at Andrew
Jackson liked to use but you know these
are these are all very complex things
than they're there's no Alexes there's
no easy answer to these questions but
technology is a you know it's it's one
of these it depends on what you're
talking about first of all whether
you're talking about a machine or an
automobile or what look at Henry Ford
for example and Ford
you know mass producing automobiles
making more Goods available for more
people
some of historians have argued that that
is an inherently demo democratizing
force more model teas available to more
people you know it's it's enhancing the
possession of material goods and at the
same time in his factory for was
probably one of the most autocratic
industrial leaders this country has ever
had and yet you know so you have these
real inconsistencies that play all the
time in the story it's one of the things
we try to bring out it's not this is not
just the story of progresses we're
trying to convey that I think the
complexities of the historical process
and the interactions that take place
another long-winded answer I'm afraid
actually it aspires me to ask Dan a
question that I'm sure he's reflected on
more this model you're talking about it
but kind of at a scientific managerial
expertise that's disinterested that
serves the good of the people more than
the people can serve their own good is
there any substitute at all or is it all
illusion that is I think that that as
the 20th century progressed and science
and technology became ever more
pervasive in the lives of our people
whether it's in national security or the
environment or in medical the medical
care system or in communications or what
have you
the idea that expertise was necessary
imperative to control expertise became
unavoidable there is no way that we
could be dealing with the with
contemporary environmental problems
without experts dealing with them no way
we wouldn't even know about what no it's
always contested but it the the point
that you need expertise it seems to me
to be increasingly unavoidable whether
you have whether the expertise that is
exercised is disinterested and
dominantly concerned with an overall
public good that's where it becomes
problematic and an issue of politics but
to say that we could do without
expertise either in the generation of
the goods and services that we have
learned to depend upon so much or in the
the control and regulation of those
goods and services for overall
democratic purposes and a public good I
think that that's just beyond question
now that it's impossible to do without
that expertise one one dramatic case in
point is that without scientists we
would not even know about global warming
right there would not be an issue
because we wouldn't know it's occurring
but with the scientists we do know that
it seems to be occurring and so we have
to do something about it
but doing something about it requires us
to strike at the very core of or the
very foundation of our of contemporary
advanced industrial civilization which
depends fundamentally on the burning of
fossil fuels fossil fuels when it burnt
when they burned produce co2 that's it
there's no way around it so the the fact
that the current President Bush simply
said when he was asked to abide by the
Kyoto treaty he said no we're not going
to do it because it's going to interfere
with our standard of living well it's
true it would interfere with our
standard of living if we were to do
something serious about it so we have on
the one hand a conflict between on the
one hand the overarching world interest
in doing something about global warming
and the local parochial interests of our
own country if you will in the ongoing
burning of fossil fuels and sooner or
later there's going to be a crunch is
going to come but with you could not
understand that issue without signs
without some injured
election of Science and Technology into
the narrative of this story well we will
have to leave you properly inflicted and
thank you all for joining us this
evening and thank the authors as well
inventing America is published by WW
Norton & Company visit wwm for more
information next week on history on book
TV